avec un peu trop sexy ici pour que le
traité dépasse le projet de
sedusa Colonisation de la Laconie testily une condition
Tommo humide sadhu brezza Casali
retards saltatoires dans la litière de cylindre crypto
Chillicothe
[Musique]
innovation
Je souhaite savoir
[Musique]
tu as  tous ont tellement sacrifié pour être ici
et faire partie de ce que nous faisons
cet équipage est composé de couples la toute
première mission de colonisation à grande échelle
et tout le monde sur terre est
vraiment reconnaissant pour le travail acharné que
nous faisons votre courage  histoire
ici c'est de la viande ou ils trouvent aussi dans la
végétation humaine ces loin de Marie qui grimpent
dedans
[Musique]
tu entends que quoi rien pas d'oiseaux pas d'
animaux rien
ce qui s'est passé ici
[Musique]
ce qui se passe maintenant il est parti Bobby
Easter propia
tout  c'est pour commencer une nouvelle vie
où est-ce saint
[Musique]